So the first 2 we're talking about the amount of work.
And the correct answer is it takes n - 1 operations.
To add up n elements takes n - 1 adds.
Next, is its work complexity order of n? Yes, it is.
So the amount of work that we do is linear with respect to the size of the input.
If we double the size of the input,
we're going to double the number of additions that we do.
Is its step complexity O(1), meaning independent of the size of input?
No, its step complexity is also linear in the size of the input.
As we double the size of the input, we'll double the number of steps to take to reduce all these items.
So to sum up, our serial reduction algorithm has a work complexity of O(n).
What that means is that the amount of work is linear in the size of the input.
If we double the size of the input, we double the number of operations that we're doing.
Our step complexity is also O(n), meaning again that if we double the size of the input
we double the number of steps it takes to compute the output.